We've already seen that enzymes
catalyze reactions, but let's explain once more how they do it.
This is our enzyme, we have a substrate,
which is associated with the active center
of the enzyme.
It is associated with this part of the enzyme,
which we call an active center.
The substrate binds to the active site and the enzyme catalyses
reaction. It can divide the substrate
of two smaller molecules.
After the reaction
the enzyme
remains unchanged,
but the reaction is catalysed.
Now we have a substrate that is divided,
in this case at least two smaller molecules.
I can draw them. This is one.
And here is the other one.
They come from the active center.
Once the reaction is catalysed, they no longer have it
affinity to the active center and detach themselves.
The enzyme has catalysed the reaction.
In this video I want to explain how this process can be inhibited
and more specifically,
how it can be inhibited competitively.
We will talk about competitive inhibition.
Competitive -
I'll write it here.
Competitive
inhibition.
We will begin with the classic variant of competitive inhibition:
when there is a molecule that competes
with the active center substrate.
As we shall see, this is not the only form
of competitive inhibition, but it is the one that
most often can be found in textbooks.
Again, we have our enzyme.
This is the enzyme.
We have already seen that this part,
which I surround, is the active center.
Active Center.
If the molecule, the exact substrate
get to the active center we will have
the first scenarios here above.
However, in the classical competitive inhibition,
or at least the version I'm going to show right now,
we may have another molecule,
which may seem like this.
It will compete for the active center
and if he comes to him first,
if he gets first,
let me show what happens.
Then we have our enzyme,
we also have the other molecule, which is not the substrate,
it connects to the active center first.
Now the predetermined substrate,
the one with which the enzyme can catalyze a reaction,
can not be linked to the enzyme, therefore the reaction will not occur.
You can see very clearly that they are competing
for the enzyme and in this case,
for the active center.
This is not the only form of competitive inhibition.
Another type of competitive inhibition
is allosteric competitive inhibition.
Let me write it.
We have allosynthetic--
Allosteric
competitive
inhibition.
Today I find it hard to write.
Inhibition.
The allosteric center is different from the active center.
In allosteric competitive inhibition
or competitive allosteric inhibition
we have a case,
where the competitor does not connect to the active center,
but with a different center,
called the allosteric center.
The competitor can connect here,
this is clearly not the active center.
The competitor may look like this.
It does not connect to the active center,
but when it connects here, the active center can no longer connect
with the intended substrate, so we have the same effect.
We have the same effect as this substrate
will not connect to the active center.
But if the substrate connects first -
Let's draw this case.
If the intended substrate is first connected,
then the competitor can not connect.
In this case, if the substrate succeeds
to get to the active center,
the competitor can not connect,
so the two molecules compete again.
I will draw the competitor here.
It is essential that
which of the two molecules, the substrate or the competitor will get first to the enzyme.
In this situation, the competitor will not contact.
This is true if we talk about
competitive inhibition whereby the molecules compete
for the active center. If the competitor gets first,
the substrate will not connect.
The reaction will not be catalyzed.
But if the substrate gets first,
the competitor will not be able to connect.
We may have a situation,
where the competitor will not be able to connect,
because the substrate has come to
active center first.
When talking about allosteric competitive inhibition,
again we have competition for the enzyme.
Only one of the two competing molecules will connect.
If one gets to the enzyme first,
the other will not be able to connect.
They compete for the enzyme, but the competitor,
which is not a substrate, is associated with the allosteric center.
By associating with the allosteric center,
the competitor changes the conformation of the enzyme,
so that the active center can no longer connect to the substrate.
I want to pay special attention to this,
because when I first taught him I told myself,
"Oh!"
Very often it can be confusing,
because if you read on the internet, you may encounter sources,
which call allosteric inhibition
uncompetitive because the competitor and the substrate do not fight
for the active center. But this is not the case.
In case of uncompetitive inhibition for which
I will make a separate video -
In non-competitive inhibition, the inhibitor
can be associated with the enzyme, regardless of whether the substrate
has been linked or not, but when the inhibitor binds,
it prevents the reaction from continuing.
The inhibitor changes the conformation of the protein,
so that it can no longer catalyze the reaction.
In noncompetitive inhibition both the substrate and the inhibitor may bind,
but if the inhibitor is bound,
the reaction will not take place.
In competitive inhibition, whether we are talking
for allosteric or non-parasite competitive inhibition,
only one - or the substrate or inhibitor
will be able to connect to the enzyme.
They compete for the enzyme.